welcome
and thanks for joining us today we're
going to be talking about how google
cloud observability suite of products is
creating a better developer experience
for its customers i'm brian zimmerman
product manager with google cloud and
i'm meredith hassett developer advocate
at corvid by wix
as i mentioned we're going to be talking
about specific tools that help
developers be more successful day-to-day
but these exist
within a larger ecosystem and this tool
set is based off the same planet scale
core platform
that powers google's internal
observability so you know it's been
battle tested
in addition it comes with built-in
zero-day
observability for key google services
this is all under the umbrella of our
logging and monitoring products but it
includes much more
when talking about how to help
developers day-to-day we first have to
ask
what do developers deeds from their
observability tool set
when we talk to our customers there are
three key themes that we see
first they need to diagnose issues
quickly
when there's an issue with your
application or site there isn't time to
go hunting for
logs or hunting for metrics you need to
be able to find the problem
and diagnose the problem with ease
second some problems are harder to find
than others
and with the large data available about
your application and the infrastructure
it runs on
especially in the cloud having a tool
set that helps you effectively find
needles in that haystack
is really important thirdly
not all issues can be reproduced in a
development environment
and even if they can be it's time
consuming
and sometimes you need answers quickly
so being able to debug
in production is often critical to
reducing mean time to resolution and
being effective in the cloud
we're going to be talking about each of
these areas with specific examples
of how they can help developers be more
effective
first of all let's talk about diagnosing
issues quickly
metrics are a key part to understanding
problems and what's happening with your
system
traces and logs have the context and
details to help you diagnose the cause
of said issues but they're not always
linked together
so going from a metric to the requests
and logs that generated that particular
metric data point
is difficult and important to be able to
diagnose issues quickly
what's the solution a feature we call
example traces
otherwise known as trace exemplars in
the screenshot on the left you can see a
heat map distribution of latency
that has two important additions one
there are aggregate percentile lines
that help us understand
how this distribution is trending second
there are example distributed traces
that have been sampled
these represent complete requests and
you can actually drill into that request
without leaving the context of your
monitoring tool
which you'll see in a moment
now let's see this in action the demo
we're about to show you
is of our example application called
online boutique
in this scenario users of the
application who normally experience
great performance have started to notice
extremely degraded latency
the developer in the video will show you
how to use the google cloud operations
tool suite
and example traces as i mentioned
earlier to quickly diagnose said issue
here we will show how we can use cloud
monitoring
and cloud trace to quickly understand
where we should be focusing our
attention
with regards to a particular issue
in this case we have an alert related to
99th percentile latency
which has spiked quite significantly
recently
drilling into our performance dashboard
we can see that there was a significant
increase in latency around the time of
the alert
this seems to possibly correlate
with error rate but not exactly
this increase can be shown both by the
distribution itself but also the
aggregate percentile lines and how they
have increased over time
let's drill in further to the inflection
point
now typically this is actually quite
difficult to go from here
understanding the specific requests that
led to that metric data point
is not always easily available however
with google cloud operations we can
overlay example traces
onto this metrics graph now we can
easily without switching context drill
into exactly what was happening
at the time the issue was observed
so in this instance this is a call to
the product service
which is making a call to get product
and making further calls to get
product which is an interesting behavior
out of the seven seconds duration about
6.9 of them were related to get product
let's see if this seems to correlate
with other types of requests
this is another similar such product
call which has a similar profile of
child calls to the product catalog
service
this here is a cart operation so that's
different
however when we look further it has the
same
get repeated get product call in the
product catalog
service that we saw earlier
and if we look further we're going to
see similar behavior
of product catalog service operations
representing the majority of the latency
now to be sure of this let's compare
with traces prior to the issue here's a
similar get product call
and it's making calls the recommendation
service
again to the get product service
it makes a few calls to get product
which is what we saw
before however if you look at the total
latency
only 31 milliseconds were spent within
the get product service this compares to
20 seconds and some of the other
examples we were
investigating
so it definitely seems to be a delta in
the length of time of get
product calls that is representative of
this latency
at this point i have a viable hypothesis
for what caused this issue
and i got there without actually leaving
my monitoring dashboard
from here i would look at logging
perhaps debugging
error reporting to try and understand
what was actually causing this issue
but what we've shown here is that with
these integrated tools
you can quickly understand where you
should be focusing your attention
and where the problem may be located
the previous example focused on speed
but that's not always what you need when
it comes to finding needles in the
haystack
it's about breadth depth and
thoroughness of your tool set
in the next example we're going to show
how you can use the google cloud
operations tool suite
to look for a very difficult to find
cause of an issue
this focuses on logging and trace and
we'll follow that up with profiler
to demonstrate finding a needle in the
haystack
we're going to look through cloud
monitoring cloud
starting with cloud monitoring we see
that we have an alert related to
latency
looking at our dashboards in specific
the performance dashboard we see that
there actually was a spike
in the errors on the front end that
occurred fairly recently
to troubleshoot this we're going to
drill into things with cloud logging
looking the logs viewer i can very
easily filter
for the log lines that contain error i
can also drill down to
the kubernetes resource type where the
errors came from
in this case they're almost all from the
front end so what's happening in these
instances
drilling in to the details for these
logs i can see what's happening
in this case i see failed to get
recommendations
i expect that other errors are very
similar
fail to get product recommendations
again
i can add this to the summary line in
order to see how prevalent this error is
within my filter criteria
now to understand what the
recommendation service is doing
let's open cloudtrace
and in this case i'm going to filter
for spans otherwise known as service
calls
where my front end is calling
my recommendation service
we can see that the latency spiked
heavily around the time that i received
the alert
and started receiving those errors
let's see what's happening what we can
see here
is after calling list recommendations
the system is making multiple calls
to get product from the product catalog
service that's interesting
in fact in this 19 second trace which
started as a get cart request almost
all of the latency is spent within those
get product calls
that's definitely not what we want to
see and it suggests that that's where
the issue
is occurring
we're going to use cloud logging to
understand what's happening within that
product catalog
service again it's very easy to find
this out by drilling in
to the resource type in the field
explorer
we're going to filter for the pod named
product catalog service
now what we can see is roughly at the
time of the error there is a
massive spike in logs from this service
narrowing down to this time interval we
can see that almost all of these logs
are successfully parsed product catalog
at this point it's safe to assume that
this is where i should focus my
attention
i'm going to open up my ide and
understand what's happening
with the parsing of the product catalog
to find out why is it actually
successfully parse the product catalog
so often
this is a good example of how to use the
operations toolset
including logging trace monitoring
and more to quickly narrow down a hard
to find problem
sometimes a problem can't be easily
found in the logs
or the traces it has to do more with the
functioning of your running code
or perhaps it's about cost optimization
this is where profiler
is extremely useful kellyanne is going
to show you
how you can use profile to solve these
needle in the haystack type problems
cloud profiler can help developers
understand how their services
are spending compute and memory
resources we will explore
how profiler can be used to identify
optimization opportunities
and help you run your services more
efficiently
profiler supports four languages java
go node.js and python for this
walkthrough
we will use the product catalog service
and its cpu time
profile type the default view for
profiler
is the flame graph view shown here it
helps developers understand
which portions of their code are using
the most resources
in this service we can see that the
stack
with the function parse catalog is using
the most cpu time or about 72 percent
we can see the parse catalog is calling
the json and marshall function
so this has to be the first focus of our
investigation
now let's open the top functions table
and
sort the functions list by the self time
we can see that 8.3 percent of cpu time
is spent in the function state in string
which is not evident from the default
view
shown in the flame graph
by clicking on this function name we
load the fling graph in the focus filter
mode
this mode is useful to identify
functions
which are called from multiple locations
in your code
it also helps us understand the various
calling paths
into this function this is very useful
for understanding the resource usage
patterns
of library functions which may be called
from
different locations in your code
removing the focus filter resets the
flame graph to its default view
now let's examine how we can use the
weight filter
to identify profiles within a selected
percentage of
peak consumption for example
top 10 percent indicates that only
profiles that were collected during the
top 10 percent of cpu consumption
are presented for analysis we can also
use the compare to
function to compare profiles from two
different weight groups
here we are comparing profiles from the
top 10 percent
with all profiles the frames
that are shaded in orange
have higher resource consumption when
compared with
all profiles we can see that there is
some increase in resource consumption
in the client handshake function stack
as well resetting the compare to
loads the default flame graph view
so these are some of the features of
profiler that can be used
by developers to understand how their
services
are spending resources and where they
should start
their optimization efforts
our final scenario talks about how to
debug code
when it counts if you've ever had a
scenario
where you could not reproduce an issue
in your development environment
then this is for you if you've ever had
a scenario where that one line of
logging
that you needed was not there when you
needed it
this is for you in this next demo
we're going to see how cloud debugger
can help you debug in production
when you need it most
to start this journey we're going to
open error reporting
error reporting automatically surfaces
errors found in the logs for easy
discoverability
within the error group we can see the
trend where this error has occurred
where in the code this error has
occurred and easily linked to the logs
that generated the error
exploring these logs we can see quite
easily
that this is exclusively caused by the
currency service
we can inspect the logs for further
details
including resource context
however this doesn't actually show us
what's happening and causing this
particular problem
for that we're going to open cloud
debugger
debugger allows us to see what is
happening in our actual running
production code
in the logs you saw that the error was
happening at line 55
of the currency service server js
clicking here we can take a snapshot of
what's happening at the code at that
exact position
inspecting the details of the variables
this was done without restarting the
service
without pausing the service completely
safe in production
now the cause isn't obvious here but we
can see from the code that if
results.units is not greater than zero
it would throw this error so let's see
what results.units
is set at in this case
it's set at not a number so that's
obviously not going to work let's see
how this was actually set
and in this case where we set that value
was also
not a valid number as such it will
generate the error that you saw today in
the logs
next we would need to update the code to
resolve this issue but you can see how
with production debugging this was easy
to find
without any impact to my system
and that concludes our three scenarios
next we're going to hear from meredith
hassett
from wix thanks brian at corvord by wix
we're all about developer velocity
and using tools like google cloud
operations really helps developers speed
up their process
corvette enables a javascript web
development environment on top of wix
sites
which enables developers to add
additional console logging as well as
error handling
that's crucial for their logging
experience by integrating
google cloud operations into corvid
developers are able to rapidly debug
issues that come up in production and
make sure their users are getting the
best experience
let's take a look at how a real-life
corvette developer uses
corvid and google cloud operations to
build and debug issues in on their site
let's take a look at a vacation booking
site where users can provide their
preferred check-ins
and check out dates to get updated quote
information about their requested
holiday
we're able to do this using corporate
and wix
to get dynamic information from third
parties displayed on our screen
let's take a look at how this looks in
the code
in our wix editor we now see a new site
structure and code ide
pane that becomes available once we
enable corvid
corvette is our web development platform
for wix sites that opens up
apis as well as ui functionality
for you as a developer
when we find the request quote function
we can see it's actually coming from the
back end
and the logify file so if we go ahead
and take a look
at our logify file in our back end
we're able to find the request quote
function and see that it's calling
an api to return booking information
about a property based off the user's
inputs
once that quote's returned we may
actually want to do some error handling
to determine if there's any issues with
the quote so let's go ahead and log
quote information and then
check to see if the quote has any error
codes
if there is an error code we may want to
return
an error status to be able to better
debug
we're able to pass through properties
from the quote as well
to the error once our error handling and
logging is in place
if we publish this will make our site
changes productive
with our production site up and ready to
go let's go ahead and enable the logging
back on our wix site dashboard when we
go to settings
production tools site monitoring we're
able to easily connect
to the google cloud operations logging
tools
when we connect we just connect with our
google single sign-on account
and we're able to get to the dashboard
once we're in the google cloud dashboard
we're able to look at the logs
for our site so let's take a look at
what a user's flow may look like and how
we can do some error handling
back in my wix editor i'm going to go to
view site
and on my site i'm going to go through a
user flow of trying to book a vacation
let's take a look at the properties that
are available and select one that looks
like a nice vacation home
once i'm on the vacation properties page
i'm able to play around with the quote
information
and see how changing my requested dates
will change
my quote information we can go through
trying to book this site as well
i now will try to place my booking
as a user if i run into any issues i can
process information back along to the
agency and see if they can help me
figure out what's going on
as a developer to make sure that your
site is healthy if we take a look back
at our logs
we're able to retrieve if there is any
information and find any errors
i can filter down for my errors see that
there was an issue with a quote
retrieval
and determined what went wrong by taking
a look at the information
and the other events logged around it
having integrated tools
like google cloud operations for logging
of websites
like those built on corvaid by wix
enables us as developers to do our jobs
more efficiently
spend less time looking for errors and
be able to resolve any issues that our
users may be having when they're coming
to our sites
thanks meredith and there you have it
we've demonstrated how google cloud
operations suite of products
can help make developers more effective
and efficient day to day
feel free to reach out for more
information or as always
visit us at cloud.google.com